how's it going resumes welcome back to
another episode of some course party I'm
excited to keep playing it's high it's
like somebody was thrown from the other
end of the hall at superhuman speed she
did the frickin wall dispute demolish
then I ship them so much look at them so
cute together just splattered everywhere
it smells so meaty
Oh God
oh she's throwing up sorry are you okay
no me I'm I'm fine let's just get away
from here
she just goes inside her house that
going away I'd really like how the game
is all the characters are so cute and so
innocent and like all these disgusting
horrible things is happening I love it
it's just such a oh god what is that the
mostly bleached skeletal remains of a
female student lies scrawled across the
floor nice loose bones and scraps of
clothing are dangling from a hole in the
ceiling above the body suggesting she
fell to her death from the second floor
god damn it
upon closer inspection there's a student
ID name tag attached to what's left on
the uniform what's the name yuzuha
becoming name tag list updated so I can
collect name tags alas is wonderful
let's read this I told everyone then I
go with them
so why have I been left behind it hurts
it hurts so much it looks like there
really have been a lot of different
people brought here pretty much
[Music]
it'll work out for us though I'm sure of
it
probably not we already know they're
gonna die a horrible death but that
leaves a little tie together hopefully I
feel like there's gonna be a tragic
ending to this okay another blue ball of
if you wish to leave this place you must
take heed of the messages left behind
left behind by the many other victims
who died damaged many victims have left
their thoughts or even their dying
messages on the scraps of paper that
neither of these walls it hurts so much
was that him
so we found his message that's kind of
interesting I like that I like that a
lot girl all right where should we go
left or right this looks bad let's go
everywhere looks bad in this game the
door seemed attached to the wall like a
sculpture it won't budge in the
slightest
what what happened to the volume Oh God
I don't like this the door is nailed
shut it definitely won't be opening
anytime soon
do not enter under any circumstances
principal takamina
Jana go hurry god damn it this thing
with like since the game not much
happens but soon does the slightest
thing happens you're like oh my gosh my
head is splitting it's unbearable I
can't take it I can't take it I can't
take it when we found ya zu Hause body I
saw a black shadow but I didn't tell
anyone about it and now it's killed them
all I'm so sorry everybody I'm so sorry
the lower half of the decks is obscured
by a thick layer of dried blood I don't
like that at all
let's keep No all right so the Vorlon
comes back here I like that it makes me
feel safe let's go in here
this looks like a dead end no it's fine
oh god what is that what is going on
here we can't go there
this is [ __ ] creepy man supposedly
this game is not supposed to be the
scariest game but it's more focused on
story and and gore which I'm actually
okay with because I'm really interested
by it
oh god what is this a crumpled up note
fell from the skeletons hand you're an
idiot point Oh if you don't believe with
all your heart then we'll never get
rescued
I thought we were friends what am i what
do you mean believe in all your heart oh
god the skeleton remains the hook girl
with a big hole in her skull are still
sitting on the chair close inspection
reveals a student ID nametag
well I guess we got to take it Asuka Kat
oh great thank you
what are those purple things what is
that I don't like that let's get out of
here [ __ ] day oh no he wasn't there
before was he someone else thought it go
in your head if you don't keep a close
eye on it that light's gonna that
light's gonna run away from you pay
attention to its location find the exact
spot where it was stood and examine it
thoroughly so here is that all I don't
get it
what's gonna hide it all Nagorny [ __ ]
talk when we come in the back it jumps
to the front yeah you're right up today
buddy tall so how about one of us waits
for it over there okay
let's remember its spot okay I noted it
I don't like it but I've noted it Thank
You blue light of death and suffering oh
how great you are all right it's here
it's this spot where we saw that weird
little thing yes
[ __ ] you okay you stay there I don't
like the fact that we're getting
separated but we don't really have much
of a choice
actually we do we could just ignore this
entire thing but wait I don't remember
okay so it's right there where did it go
she got it
you did nice job what is it
turn out to be this
yes infirmary I know what that is you
could take on yes it goes to show you
what a little teamwork in the way we
make a great team that's so cute so cute
hashtag skill skill all right the
infirmary is upstairs and then down I
think or maybe just here I want to check
here this is the infirmary isn't it yes
you see form Ricki the door is now
online yeah Oh save station yeah it's a
panel I don't know whatever we should
find something in here vast quantities
of medicine and tonics are lined up on
the edge of the shelves along with a
single bottle of rubbing alcohol and we
should take it what do they need on
these for we could use it for like if we
get hurt the handle turns but not in
trouble of water no I didn't realize
this now thirsty I am there has to be
something here isn't it they can't just
leave us here with it it's an old
fashioned space heater a box of matches
on the ground next to it takes boys
acquired box of matches
[Music]
I wonder what that's all about
I'm sure we'll find out sooner or later
maybe we can go into it let's not forget
to read these wash your hands with soap
thanks note what else would you wash
your hands with seriously God what is
this human body looking close it seems
like someone's painted over each of the
organs with actual blood nice
nice I do that too in my head that's
what happens when you don't get a hobby
weird [ __ ] like that okay I don't know
food there's a box there it's a loose
board take it with you
yes I know where we can use it we use it
up here I really enjoy playing this game
it's been a while since I got so
immersed into something so quickly
see that's what that's what a long story
introduce for you place in this board
try it
admit it
alright and see what's up here oh god
someone is following us more disgusting
creatures of the death a pile of
haphazardly stood hume buzz leave it
upon the floor upon closer examination a
student ID name tag can be seen jutting
out from one side Sasha she known God
will surely save me well I'd sure like
doesn't look like it buddy boys room to
the left girls room at the end of the
hall okay let's check out the boys room
urinal ammonia
it's almost staggering nice ah well I
guess he don't walk in the boys pooping
listen learn girls listen and learn what
the hell was that that was either an
actual voice or an auditory as a
hallucination and I really don't know
which is more likely but that [ __ ] what
is going on here this is very strange
more people 'it's unidentified rusted
the rested bucket completely crawling
with man yet thanks for that image game
thank you very kindly all right what if
you got mad
thing that's dead that's dead net it
won't open
well that's [ __ ] weird I don't think
we can do anything else here to be
honest one do you have any of that ass
medicine on you by any chance you know
the smeary stuff well this is getting
juicy hello what again yep
my butt's been drier than the desert
since we got here well I got some
antibacterial creams if that will work
thank ya I'm gonna I'm gonna go I'm
gonna I'm gonna go butter up my poop
butter up my poop er butter up my pooper
is that is that is that what you guys do
when you go to the restroom if this is
an actual representation of what women
doing cuz I don't know
I don't vote off my pooper thank you
very much with it real good
excited do you have any shame at all
this fog
can I go with that big brother that's
weird
is that you can I don't know whatever
guy here oh thank god she's here at
least ah nothing just making sure you're
here don't scoot sorry for the wait
thanks for the cream now they put her
there
you know what you can keep it it's a
quatre oh no problem
hey wait was that stole open yeah it
wasn't open mm-hmm I thought that stall
was locked when we were in there before
Oh God
was it I didn't have any trouble getting
in fine I guess I'll let you off the
hook we have bigger things to worry
about after all
actually just heard yuccas voice out in
the hallway I think was coming from
downstairs
really let's go check it out you know I
can I'm kind of curious about the
bathroom well it's still open it won't
open
weird that is weird man I don't know
what's up for that all right let's see
if we can find Yuka I think you'll get a
tiny girl that photo she stole
Oh God ah Malay thanks for letting me
ahead seems like you sprained your ankle
really badly no we should find you
someplace to sit down and depressed yeah
probably right here into my shoulder for
the time being that's the world wall
Thanks
[Music]
you missing a nice
[ __ ] you okay so we have a candle in our
inventory but that's pretty much it I
wouldn't know where else to go to be
honest ow
oh god I think I step in it did you hear
I got some tissue dude maybe you can
wipe it off
these are definitely someone's get
whatever part of their body I stepped on
it made a species down like I just
plopped by she wouldn't choose a pile of
dog Jersey pollen that's way too much
information you're gonna make me jack oh
[Music]
god that's disgusting what the [ __ ]
they're really good at describing [ __ ]
literally we've been in here I mean we
didn't find much except the candles what
happens in here what is this
you weren't here before if you should
die here you'll experience the pain you
felt at the moment of death for all
eternity oh nice
that's just [ __ ] swell can't wait
heavens completely cut off no paradise
no nirvana this eternal pain why did it
have to die like that
another what is this okay unknown so
we'll feel the pain of death forever
okay we got a key that we don't know
where it goes
can we inspect it maybe or some [ __ ]
like that
oh oh
I'd randomly clicked my god it seems to
fit the lock perfectly the door coming
down okay
Oh God if mmm no me what's wrong I don't
know it's like my heart skipped a beat
as soon as the key was turned I have a
really bad feeling about this room Oh
trust me oh good just fine
I mean it's a locked door you know what
that means right buddy behind every
locked door lives a hidden treasure
just waiting to be claimed can't you
hear it calling for you I love the booty
I love the big booty of course we're
gonna enter
Oh God maybe there wasn't the best of
ideas hello EEP another dead body a
message have has been painstakingly
scratched into the floor with
fingernails whatever you do do not look
at the newspaper I really think we
should just leave this trim something's
not right in here but I don't know I'm
really curious about that newspaper now
can't we just take one little peek oh my
god what is this let's check this out
first there's a candle here but it's
unlit well we can lit it we have the
candle yeah I know but we can we used a
I don't think I can use it right now I
think we have to check the newspaper
breaking news
serial kidnapping ends in murder the
good name of heavenly host elementary
school has been stained in blood today
as horrific details on the news a recent
wave of disappearances are revealed over
the past month numerous children have
gone missing within the town and
authorities quickly turned to kidnapping
as the most likely explanation well I
guess that makes sense
now investigators are located the
whereabouts of these children and their
findings are far worse than anyone could
have anticipated the bodies of the
sconed
youth were discovered within the
heavenly host elementary school building
in September 18th 1973 at ground 7 p.m.
authorities further revealed that a male
instructor from the school was fun with
them alive but near catatonic holding a
pair of bloodied scissors each of the
corpses appeared to have had its tongue
oh and removed relations far too great
to describe the page is torn at this
point in the bottom half of the article
is nowhere to be found
hey guys again how awful I think I heard
about this no once before not me but I
guess it happened long before we were
born so I shouldn't be too surprised
Oh God what happened what happened I got
goose nips oh god the door seems to the
wall fixed to the wall like a decoration
it won't open
Oh God I mean [ __ ] shouldn't have
touched that means paper what do we do
what do we do oh my god that is creepy
oh god no no the doors no no
oh it's crying there's a candle here
Pizza just literal ready what do we do
there's no way out what do we do
you gotta this is your fault you know
what how it's never mind
that was no one's fault
there's no point of blaming each other I
can walk here
doesn't really help us Oh God Oh what
happened oh man let's scare the crap out
of me hold up
oh no no it's gone what is Oh No the
paper dolls crap I got for a Mayumi oh
the sharm mind stealing my student ID
holder crap I put mine in my pocket it
must have fallen out somewhere that's
why I keep telling you you need to put
things away before they get lost now I'm
sad
I have a feeling this is gonna have bad
consequences and so me why did we go in
here again I don't like this place
Shh we got a name tag okay good
god I don't know what to do now we need
to find another one of these I don't
know how or where or when or why or what
or whom or rid what that's all I know
[Music]
some I expected events to be a lot
dustier yeah I think I'm going to lie
down for a bit
are they gonna sleep together I wonder
if there's anything in here we could use
to sue that ankle of yours
sit tight know me I'm gonna take a look
okay thanks a bunch
don't thank me yet
I haven't done anything that's true hey
is she finding anything well not by the
desk you'll won't find anything there
yeah it'll do nicely
I got me a makeshift splint and some
bandages that sprains a goner now hold
still oh man you're a lifesaver
there's so kill feels great
psycho thank you hey you're welcome I
sprained my ankle pretty badly before
too so I know just how you feel I wish I
had some eyes or something to put on it
though no worries you've done more than
enough already you're asleep now that's
very
I guess glad you agree hey it's
Slumberland for me
you're really an oddball you know that
I'm so cute oh look at that
so hey now me if we find mushy dad have
you thought about what do you want to do
with him huh I don't think sleep naked
[Music]
well you know what they say when two
people are faced with difficult
situations shall we say it often leads
to love sweet love you should well up
all your courage and confess your
feelings to him you get old girlie with
him in this creepy place and your
cuteness factor will grow three times
size three sizes in his eyes I bet is
that how you girls do it huh finding all
the secrets I swear with you around I
almost feel like we're just soo shoot
who wouldn't the breeze bag at school
like nothing's ever happened that's
adorable thank you for your advice don't
think about it I hope we find him soon
let's go to sleep already you're
thinking about how you wish he didn't
have to be put through all this you want
to see him but you wish you could rest
easy knowing that he's safe sound back
home rather than wandering around here
am i right must be those maternal
instinct the beer is kicking in huh
you're a deep one to be sure she may
sound like an idiot
but she's right on all counts guess
there's no fooling sicko I've been
pretty Curt with her since we got here
I'll have to make sure I apologize later
yeah you better and what was that
exactly what hey sorry sister when I see
that ass
Oh yos I start to draw you are so weird
oh my god that's yoga that was Yuka
again I heard it too
I'll take a look you stay here and rest
okay I'll be back in a jiffy I don't
think that's such a good idea I should
go too
I insist don't worry I'll be fine just
keep Dada ass parked on that band you
got it man I I need to write this [ __ ]
down this is a great great material well
better look your anchors all dressed and
feeling better right don't make it all
for nothing all right I guess I'll stay
here alright I'm sorry about the spokes
end here for today go ahead and leave it
like right now if you enjoy watching I
very much appreciate it and I will see
you tomorrow
style some bras love you
[Music]